[Music]
2017 is far from over and yet there have
been an astounding number of games
already released this year you likely
heard about Resident Evil 7 and Mass
Effect Andromeda but numerous other
games have launched in 2017 that you may
have missed and are still well worth
checking out we've rounded up six such
games for Xbox one but be sure to hit
the subscribe button below to get our
recommendations on other platforms in
the coming days
[Music]
one game that may have gone unnoticed
but is worth a look is thimble we'd park
a point-and-click adventure by famed ex
LucasArts duo Ron Gilbert and Gary
Winnick tumbleweed park deals with a
murder in the small town of thimble weed
park that two FBI agents have to
investigate it rides a thin line between
nostalgia and reinvention balancing its
comically written nods to the genre with
some modern design choices well it
sometimes sticks too closely to the
point click genres long-held mechanics
then what we park is great for
experience adventure game fans eager to
experience a whimsical narrative and
solve some puzzles
Forza horizon 3 was already arguably the
best racing game of the generation and
it's only gotten better through DLC
their first expansion took players to a
wintery landscape but this year's
hotwheels DLC is the stuff of childhood
fantasies it allows you to get behind
the wheel of classic Hot Wheels cars and
drive them around wild course is
comprised of loops and huge jumps better
yet the courses are constructed from the
signature orange Hot Wheels tracks these
weave around some gorgeous island
settings and feature new boost pads that
provide a sense of speed unlike anything
else in port so it's downright
exhilarating when you leap across a
chasm or go zooming past a giant
animatronic dinosaur for the first time
ukulele was originally pitched as a
spiritual successor to banjo kazooie and
that certainly wasn't an exaggeration
like the classic Nintendo 64 platformer
ukulele stars in a penny miss duo in
this case a lizard named Yuka and a bat
named Leigh Leigh and has players used
their abilities to explore colorful
worlds and pick apart all manner of
collectibles ukulele channel's the
spirit of banjo kazooie so well that it
genuinely feels like a long-lost antenna
64 platformer for better and sometimes
for worse but even during its moments of
frustration ukulele remains one of the
most charming releases of the year
thanks to its tongue-in-cheek writing
beautiful art style and whimsical
soundtrack while it may not top at
banjos first two adventures it certainly
sets along rares antenna 64 output
nicely anyone who grew up with nineties
platformers and has a fondness for rare
games in particular will find a lot to
love about ukulele
roguelikes have become wildly popular in
recent years but few have taken as
interesting of an approach to the genre
as crypt of the necrodancer it tasks
players but navigating a dungeon to the
beat of the music instead of just moving
are attacking freely you and your
enemies actions are tied directly to the
excellent soundtrack further
complicating things is the need to
always be doing something if you skip a
beat without acting your combo resets
which means you'll earn less gold and
potentially do less damage depending on
what items you've acquired especially as
the beat of the music increases there's
real tension and excitement to every new
room you enter and you have to
constantly consider what you want to do
next and how enemies might respond it's
an experience that's quite unlike
anything else and it's one that you'll
certainly want to try
[Music]
the sexy Brutale is a quirky little
puzzle game co-developed by tequila
works the studio behind the beautiful
adventure game rhyme it's essentially
Groundhog Day the game you play through
the same day over and over but with each
run-through you learn more about the
creepy mansion you find yourself in
after seeing one character shoot another
you might go and find a gun and prevent
the bloody murder by replacing real
bullets with blanks a number of these
murders are interconnected solving one
puzzle might prevent one murder but that
could change another branch of time
elsewhere in the house but discovering
and tinkering with different timelines
is where the fun lies we've played it
over and over again Groundhog Day indeed
being a roguelike style shooter enter
the gungeon naturally draws comparisons
to games like The Binding of Isaac and
nuclear throne and while that helps you
understand what it's like to play enter
the gungeon manages to rise above being
a pale imitator it feels fantastic with
a dodge roll ability that allows you to
satisfyingly evade damage with a
well-timed use there are ridiculous
weapons such as the one that fires bees
or a gun that shoots guns which
themselves fire bullets the procedurally
generated environments are well crafted
and helped keep each run feeling fresh
as do the wide variety of items and
secrets that you uncover along the way
and co-op support makes for an
especially fun and chaotic experience
the entire game is also overflowing with
personality and color making for an
experience that is as fun to look at as
it is to play this is just a small
selection of the great Xbox one games
that came out this year which you might
have missed and of course there are
plenty more so be sure to subscribe to
GameSpot for all of our Xbox one
coverage and stay tuned in the coming
days for future videos where we take a
look at hidden gems on PlayStation 4
Nintendo switch and PC
[Music]